yeah welcome to this video playing tetra
from the UK I need a solid game now
playing black side off from the Catalan
okay Quincy took now oops this is a
mouse club probably he wanted to capture
on c4 mmm okay how to continue the
special piece and prolly shouldn't be
bad 95 95 he's got a quick deform the
Queen d2 ami you just probably just a
develop no 96 intense night too well to
be four
I know now I'll take the bishop on their
forum and to go here on III a half night
before to d3 ladies allowing that maybe
it isn't it isn't so clear cut possible
I always need to be cautious about 95 in
this in this sort of position okay let's
do this these blocks I mean you some of
fixes for the pawn structure it makes
sure that I have this knight on d5 and
yeah they can he can play that but I can
always go to shoot 2d6 or f6 not sure
where maybe here
on b3 i have c 3 this is important I
don't want to take on b3 if he attacks
it ok let's prepare g5 now yeah I need
to me to get this get this going here ok
i still have found the extra ball Knight
to c3 maybe Knight c3 what is he playing
on that looks like um I'm gonna pin I'm
American pen hell naw meen good on the
longer diagonal let's do this must be
the right move freedom mmm what now
probably I should take him
I can I don't think I can just take and
player and take on take on b3 should be
all right threatening b2 + b2 b1
promoting of course this clean as a bit
a bit shaky neither 7s sir it's made to
have moved the Queen somewhere
unfortunate yeah looks like we need
three is not I'm not working multiply
this by day for maybe night a4 and b3
yaptim down on the clock anyway and big
b3 b2 I mean okay at least now is not
threatening mate may be here i am on
Queen g2 I've got 21
Mike be honest nothing no no real way to
to intercept to stop this this phone
yeah of course pretty much this the
small slip was here Quincy 23 was very
unlucky of course yeah instead of taking
you play dead and after that its own
already very nice for black with just
next to pawn at the screen is son also
rather misplaced yeah but maybe I could
have done something something better
even but it seems like blankets
preserving is his edge all the way here
the computer actually says it's equal
this is interesting why this happened in
the game right didn't it yeah and now it
gives a Bab rookie takes and now it
gives Queen d2 West equal played this
okay Queen d2 is equal yeah why on earth
is this equal
yeah one idea might be the movie for
threatening Queen G 59 f 7 so it gives
this this move and then the Queen a five
yeah possible possible but this kind of
stuff is enough for white to to
compensate he is rather active but equal
really now maybe just a strong night but
let's say I exchange and and now it is
even giving white and advantage this is
getting ridiculous it's and this is not
possible why I can never be better here
I mean I'm a porn up and where where's
your big compensation this is just a
just us just a strange assessment hmm
King GA to Queen a six well it's not so
easy to improve this black cannot move
this piece I can't move this piece
possible I mean compensation yeah but I
don't see really what is why it's doing
and in terms of making progress if I
just just move around I mean some
something Howard does he ever make any
progress you can try to to win c7 by
capturing on d5 at some stage let's say
here and then at some point take here to
to grab this but I can never be worth
with this bishop I mean it's not
possible yep interesting alright thanks
for watching